dificilmente vão conseguir manter a
franquia
bom dia a todos é como dizia o roberto
não vai contar novamente com a história
vai encontrar o segmento nessa história
é uma história que começou depois de um
trabalho de investigação desenvolvido
durante oito anos como designer
sempre pensei sempre acredita que o
design poderia ser muito mais do que
desenhava muitos objetos de maior
consumo
sempre vi o design com alto poder e
tornar o mundo melhor têm essa
competência e tem essa nova missão oito
anos de investigação oito anos de
trabalho o resultado que depois disso
não comigo só com todos que estiveram na
casa da música em 2011 com vocês
com estes quatro ou cinco anos fizeram
com que o conseguisse transformar uma
boa ideia
uma coisa é efetiva e é um caminho que
eu vou fazer aqui e para tal eu poderia
ir a ajuda dos voluntários também porque
vou distribuir os óculos que vamos dar
um carrinho por se ver o que nós temos
aqui fazer
é o engenhão
todo o trabalho e este projeto que eu
fiz é prendeu ou ensinou algumas ensinou
algumas coisas durante oito anos estive
a trabalhar como eu fui eu
depois de 2008 até agora e ao tema
ensinado muito de falar ao turismo foram
distribuídos em alguns jogos e eu eu
tenho que mais mas eu não dei algumas
pessoas eu creio que essas pessoas que
não se verão e 71 sentiram rita é
excluído discriminado é preciso me disse
que eu queria se que você sente 100
porque agora vou pedir às pessoas que
tiveram os óculos ou escolha cada mais
um facto estamos a trabalhar o motiva a
trabalhar e agora nós estamos a
trabalhar com algo que nada tenha sido
feito no mundo nunca tinha sido pensado
daltonic efetivamente esses óculos foram
distribuídos ao antes aquelas pessoas
que não estiveram sentiram que nós já
houve discriminados excluídos
discriminar foi quem teve os óculos que
não consegue seguir a diferença entre
essas duas imagens ou até mesmo entre
estas duas por exemplo embora partilhem
o sol e esta sensação que eu queria
provocar os interesses excluídos sem
saber por que apenas se os seus afinal
novos incluídos
e essa questão da partilha falamos de
uma limitação que não é visível aos
olhos dos outros que afeta 10% da
população masculina mundial 350 milhões
de pessoas no mundo não vem scott
investigação durante oito anos quando ao
tônicos com ele com o estudo profundo de
como criar uma linguagem universal
hoje vou falar aqui rapidamente só para
contextualizar o que eu fiz foi baseado
numa coisa que é óbvia para todos 90% da
comunicação que é feita no mundo é feita
através da cor ea 350 milhões de pessoas
o facto de não ver em quanto
o curso ea sociedade não a se
identificar são completamente excluídas
90% dos autônomos precisa de ajuda para
comprar roupa nos 60 por cento precisa
de ajuda em casa para escolher a roupa
que vai esquerdo 17 anos descobriu que
era daltônico depois de 20 anos sofreu
bullying perda da autoestima pela
autoconfiança de chicomba da integração
na sociedade 48% dos autônomos têm
dificuldade de integração social
em algum momento da sua vida sentiram a
vergonha ou constrangimento
seja o que for com o facto de escolher a
cor errada
procurei criar uma linguagem universal
baseada naquilo que o conhecimento
adquirido que todos nós conhecemos a
escola pra mim é muito importante
o processo é rápido simples e mais do
que tudo muito positivo
se eu pudesse marcar e da julgado eu
este projeto chamado colour lei ajuda a
cor era óbvio mas não fui por colegas
por mais condição quase que somente que
me abençoava colorido e uma palavra que
não fosse de ninguém que fosse todos
o evento terá uma ferramenta democrática
e que fosse fácil de aprender fácil
desintegrar o óleo visual do que de bom
foi a creche e guache que todos nós
temos uma escola técnica às primárias
mais branco e preto para ter uma destas
curso três filmes gráficos o joão tinha
que ser muito diferente do memorial é um
dos tipos de alpinismo e uma das missões
que aprender com este projecto é que nós
somos muito mais competentes pensar nas
coisas para os outros do por nós
próprios
há muitos tipos paulo mesmo eu não sou
autônomo se fosse ao time que o teria
encontrado uma ferramenta que permite
também comunicar com a sociedade mas
como não sou eu tenho que procurar como
é que todos os autônomos ver com feijão
verde amarela e azul e amarelo aos 30
dias de treino ea simulação que só com
os fazem as pessoas que vivem em preto e
branco e não há cura
não há nos autos iguais então é esse o
pensamento na ferramenta positiva
assento nas primárias na caixinha de
guaxupé da silva representou uma cor que
esse simples faça fácil de gravar o
áudio visual de cada um faça nuclear
numa única com menos de cinco anos e por
um senhor de 95 anos nós mais que tudo
eu senão que se ligar em treinos e
obrigar entre outros com nós aprendemos
na escola se misturar moral com
mas eu tenho um laranja então se eu
mostrar o seu nome ao consumo no
vermelho tem sim laranja três times
permitiu ao time que talento pela sec de
tinta e eu não vou ver por não
distinguir um fumante ferrari do verdão
everton mas sempre foram um fator
racional de orientação e identificação a
escolha o daltônico através do conceito
da edição do curso conceito facilmente
identificar todas as coisas
uma paleta uma linguagem porém que o
preto sus para verificar seus claros o o
olhar indiferente ficaram estamos claro
sua preferência aos tons curso o que
estava feito oito anos mas era preciso o
aval para o mundo e então segunda lição
que teve neste projeto toda a vida me
disseram que não era possível ter o
melhor dos mundos
eu não acredito esse projeto mostrou
isso é impossível ter o melhor 3 muitos
primeiro mundo daltônico uma ferramenta
sem que eu tenha que pagar por ela e
mais do que isso sem que eu tenha que
assumir a sua condição incluir 100
discriminado segundo mundo garantir um
processo e uma missão a permitem esse
projeto ambicioso início em 2011
ambicioso mas não é ganancioso se ele
chegar a 350 milhões de pessoas que eu
não sei onde estão que não tem um
ferimento na testa dizer eu sou
daltônico e tenho vários projetos entre
mil milhões de pessoas e melhor maneira
que encontrei para isso foi não fazer
sozinho
procuramos vimos portugal uma crise
profunda e potenciar as empresas de
desenvolvimento econômico das empresas
através de programas de compreensão em
que o código nos produtos das empresas
não só traz inovação impacto social como
também nos ajuda a salvar mais reduz
rapidamente este projeto está muito
portugal e agora estamos já em várias
coisas a trabalhar com ele
o que seria um mundo naturalmente
educação são as crianças que vão fazer o
mundo da manhã e isso para as crianças
têm que ser de borla sem custos cremon
injection colorado social estamos a
trabalhar nas escolas de várias áreas
por exemplo em três anos estamos
destruindo 200 âmbitos diferentes é
importante vão me dar o projeto estatal
fazer com criar crianças através de todo
um trabalho com inovação impacto social
que permitisse
rapidamente eu pudesse ser exportado
para todo mundo
se for só para atacar em portugal
descrevemos azul o vermelho o amarelo
mas não a idéia era uma ferramenta
democrática design farol design por
todos mas que fosse entendido por todos
alguns vivemos a transmissão de dados do
projeto
2 mais 2 mil caixas lápis viarco já
foram vendidas em 2011
apresentamos isso com o lançamento de um
produto que permite incluir sem
discriminar 410 mil exames nacionais ao
que usou ocorre durante o filme
daltónicos conseguem interpretar tão bem
o enunciado um problema e fazer tão bem
a formulação da proposta 160 mil manuais
escolares de ensino outras matérias
através da cor
esse foi um fator de ensinar outras
matérias o conexões para o prime time do
técnico seja incluir 600 crime e se
discriminado área hospitalar forma
hospitalares
a orientação dos hospitais triagem de
manchester transportes 210 mil
passageiros por dia já em contactos com
cólica permitir a orientação das linhas
e não nos podemos esquecer que estamos a
falar de bons maioritariamente e o homem
é o tipo que não gosta muito de parar
para perguntar por isso a idéia de
converter é tal independência criativa
em cidades já em 25 cidades através dos
mapas do turismo através dos museus de
todas as plataformas em que corta um
avanço grande do ponto de vista daquilo
que é orientação de diferentes coisas
através da core estuário
mas dez empresas testes o que usou o
código mais de 23 milhões de etiquetas
no mundo permitem o conforto do
indivíduo daltônico deste mundo obtido
poderá escolher a roupa que vai vestir
não sei que o momento é de couro e não
dependerá da ajuda de terceiros
alimentar-se mafra o tradicional
reconhecimento a se dizer parem a pouco
falavam destruir indicamento senhora
falou o juiz 42 mil contentores permitem
é a relação ea proximidade entre a
questão social ea questão ambiental a
cor como fator de identificação no mesmo
outras tecnologias desenvolvemos desde
2011 para 7
estamos a trabalhar com autistas temos
um projeto e ser ensinado na escola para
todos
em 2001 pedindo que é um trabalho que
nós queremos
eu permiti sempre disse isso é um
projeto feito por pessoas e para as
pessoas não o projeto feito por dinheiro
nem pelo dinheiro e acho que isso é a
diferença e o dinheiro naturalmente será
uma conseqüência de um trabalho feito
com paixão com competência e com
dedicação
fazemos nas escolas através de um mg um
trabalho de tentar uma versão de todas
as bibliotecas escolares através das
normativas e das recomendações da unesco
é com a suspensão desse modo universal
tem na cor um fator diferenciador
identificação das diferentes temáticos
mais do que isso se acções de
sensibilização prevenir o bullying
o meu salto única vítima de bullying
muitas vezes sem o ter naturalmente
exercido pelo próprio professor não
admite que o quinto black river ou a
copa de uma árvore do amor maio
registrando alpinismo nunca foi feito no
mundo precocemente alunos série 4º ano
estamos a monitorizar todos os miúdos
com os três da organismo prevenindo e
evitando que ele tenha 18 anos o sonho
de ser piloto da força aérea afegã aip o
fato será o técnico não poder ser e
todos indiscriminadamente a oferecer
material contém informação sobre a
questão do daltonismo sobre ferramentas
permitem os mil dos daltónicos poderem
usar sem ser discriminados se deram nos
a todos e todas podem usar sem ter que
ser rotulados usar isso porque faltando
juntamente com isso baixar o orçamento
material escolar nas famílias mais algo
de grande de grande impacto social
mas isto porque o imóvel e as pessoas
que me acompanham há 15 anos sabe
perfeitamente disso são as pessoas
luiz juliano meio da argentina que reza
por mim todas as noites na semana da
guarda porque temos realmente sofri
horrores é 9 mil quilômetros daqui
o diogo tiago assuf e joão este sim eu
acho que é isto que nós temos que pensar
neste momento vivemos uma época difícil
sair todos nós sabemos mas acredita em
mim isto é em minha visão das coisas com
todos os constrangimentos que vivemos eu
acho que é um privilégio enorme
tentei que vivemos nós nunca tiveram
estão perto cada um no nosso 17 milhões
de aves poder fazer alguma coisa por um
mundo melhor e velhos como frase
li há 30 e tal anos e não pense na rua
todos os dias mas que me acompanha
diariamente e as será que o poderá fazer
a diferença pelo mundo melhor
este é suficientemente os casos muito
obrigado